those questions from Alisha
or Lisa in Indiana she says I'm reading
the book smart money smart kids I got a
question about chores and payday did you
stand over your kids and yell to get
them to do their chores or did you leave
it up to them I'm finding that it's
become a stressful topic at our house
because my husband is standing over our
seven-year-old yelling and pushing her
every step of the way what is the right
amount of pushing I win yell at our kids
we just whip them we told you do
something you just best do it I'm not
yelling somebody get them to do stuff
I'm not a Yeller I am on stage when I'm
goofing off but I mean I'm gonna yell at
a seven-year-old now the question is do
you make the seven-year-old do chores so
here's what we did do okay all joking
and kidding aside we we told the kids
that this is what you're going to do we
let them fail by not doing the chore and
not receive the money a few times but
ultimately the goal here is not the
money the goal here is to teach the
child to work so that we can then have
an excuse to pay them commissions so
then we have an excuse to teach them
with money they quote-unquote earned
meaning they didn't really earn it
because you know it's not like you would
pay somebody any amount of money to feed
your own dog you would just feed the dog
so they don't earn money but we're
trying to create a an environment here
where we can teach them four major
lessons work and then when they get paid
we teach them three things to do with
money give some save some and spend some
and so just like with your homework I
will allow you to not do your homework
and accept a bad grade I'm not gonna
micromanage every little thing but on
that particular homework assignment I
will not allow you to not do your
homework for six weeks and
flunk the class I'll be all up in your
business and it won't be yelling but
there would be punishment and discipline
involved you will freakin do what I say
I'm the dad it's not really an
old-fashioned idea so it's a concept
some people have lost some people have
the household where the inmates run the
asylum but they didn't at the Ramseys
and so you know you're going to brush
your teeth you're going to wash behind
your ears you're going to do your
homework and ultimately these chores
that we laid out you're going to do them
because it's not the chore that I need
done it's that I want to raise a child
that becomes an adult that knows how to
work how to save how to give and how to
spend and so I'm going to ultimately
make you do that but I do want to let
them have a little bit of experience
failure and of course we're going to
talk about it a lot rather than just
assign a chore to them and go you're
gonna need this because Dave Ramsey has
a program and I bought the box of
financial peace jr. stuff and you're
gonna do it no you're going to lay it
out and talk about as your dad I don't
want your teeth to fall out of your head
so you're going to brush them as your
dad I don't want you living here
unemployed so you're going to do your
homework as your dad your mom I'm going
to teach you to work because I know 54
year olds who have never learned to do
that as your dad I'm gonna teach you to
give because the best people on the
planet are people who learn to give as
you're so long you see this is me
training you to be a successful adult
later and you can talk about that age
appropriately when they're 3 when
they're 7 when they're 10 when they're
13 the discussion sound different the
vocabulary sounds different the depth of
which would give the explanation sounds
different but at the end of the day when
you're 14 and I tell you to do something
you're gonna freaking do it just like
when you're 4 and so you know again
that's old school
some of you are worse if I'd parents and
you have no idea how to raise kids and
so you're raising hellions
and turning them loose on the culture
and the rest of us have to deal with
them then but you know the basic loving
guidance and discipline that goes with
that is part of the procedure yelling
and pushing her every step of the way am
I gonna yell at my kid to do a chore
they're just gonna do it or they're
gonna get consequences they're not gonna
like it what was it your grandmother
used to say you're not gonna be able to
sit down for a week you know hear heard
those kinds of things yeah that'll be a
little work that'll work so you know
we're gonna we're gonna work this
through that way but but yeah you need
to enforce the ultimately the goal is to
learn the lesson it's not about the
children it's not really about the money
both are really irrelevant it's the
lesson we're teaching you to be a
successful adult my friend handy Andrew
says don't raise your children to be
good children raise your children would
be great adults we're trying to train
you to be a great adult we're not trying
to train you to be a good kid if being a
good kid it takes you towards being a
good adult that's fine some of the same
characteristics are there but I really
want you to leave when you grow up
that's the idea because you know an
eagle that doesn't leave the nest is
eventually known as a turkey hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right it's kind of
better
Dave Ramsey Channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget one of the best videos out there
you